I am even leaping cheese and Steven
Nelson it is my real name and I am with
maverick The Wolverine the champ the
hull Brock the big cat the J boo the
table this sunday the tussle in Tampa
you and The Undertaker defending these
belts against the Hulk and Rikishi
what's gonna happen I'll tell you what
I'm gonna do till when I see that
Rikishi you know what I'm do too I'm
looking at this too fat to stop me are
you going to bring the fudge crunch to
the show am I gonna bring it at this
broader the whole the San Diego's
smacking me that Steve you jabroni you
can say something to you may say is out
there I don't care by those big ol
muscular shiny old up Jane apps let me
ask farms J boo Rudy Tootie I'm give the
champion punch cuz he's too back to stop
me fresh and fruity he start doing this
assets happiest punch right in his face
non praying I'm just saying Packer hey
I'm here with the heavyweight champion
of the world brethren k nobody beat me
Steve he'll lose to anybody I'm the
world champion baby you see it you want
it but you can't have people say you are
too dangerous to be a champion how would
you respond to your critics that's right
I am dangerous
just like we put earring whoa look you
got bows on cuz I'll slap you right in
their chest you know what I'm tired of
hearing you talk to see what is a go
wait wait just a minute we smack now is
in sandy XD what's your last name now it
doesn't matter what your name is to you
one thing row
just piddled it's my gun Ric Flair boy